[Music]  people are outraged that last night  during the super bowl i don't know if  you saw this ad  but there's this company groupon  and they exploited tibet's troubles to  promote their website  they sort of got you sucked in about the  problems in tibet and then it went to  their website yeah a spokesman for  groupon said to see our apology click on  our website and uh  take good care of you the controversial  this is everyone's talking about it  though timothy hutton  was talking about political strife  in tibet  and uh then the whole thing turned into  a groupon ad for tibetan food in chicago  and that made people really angry and in  any way i thought it wasn't as bad as  the other groupon ad that aired even  later in the game i thought this was  worse take a look  the hindenburg was a terrible blimp  disaster caused by a hydrogen explosion  but it's nothing like the savings  explosion you can get on a blimpy  sandwich with groupon  groupon.com  all the frugality  [Applause]